the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
hello and welcome to 507 biochemistry
online I'm doctor bog danfa de leche
let's metabolize some problems today
we're discussing problem 2 of problem
set 6 here we're going to explore in
more detail the mechanism of
phosphoglycerate mutase which is the
eighth enzyme in glycolysis the enzyme
that catalyzes the conversion of 3
phosphoglycerate to 2-phosphoglycerate
generally speaking mute cases are
enzymes that catalyze the shift of a
functional group between two similar
positions of a molecule in the case of
phosphoglycerate mutase this enzyme
catalyzes the transfer of the phosphate
group from the 3 position of glycerate
to the 2 position of glycerin in 507 you
will encounter several mute cases
similar to phosphoglycerate mutase there
is a bisphosphoglycerate mutase which
converts 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate to 2 3
bisphosphoglycerate now this reaction is
very important and it happens in the red
blood cells
another mutase you will encounter is in
the glycogen breakdown pathway it's
called phosphoglucomutase and converts
glucose 1-phosphate to glucose
6-phosphate now finally the most
intriguing of them all is the methyl
malonyl-coa
which is a fascinating enzyme that
converts methylmalonyl coenzyme and
skeleton of the molecule and it requires
adenosylcobalamin which is a cofactor
derived from vitamin b12 back to
phosphoglycerate mutase this is a
fascinating enzyme because it uses a
phosphorylated histidine in the active
site and this is actually an example of
a phosphorus nitrogen bond one of the
very few available in biochemistry
here is a schematic of the mechanism of
phosphoglycerate mutase
now the reaction starts where the enzyme
is already phosphorylated would call it
a phosphor enzyme and the histidine is
in the active site contains the
phosphate group then the enzyme binds
the substrate 3-phosphoglycerate and
then it's going to transfer this
phosphate group onto the to position to
hide
of the 3-phosphoglycerate to generate
the 2 3 bisphosphoglycerate then the
phosphate the 3 position is transferred
to the histidine to generate the product
of the reaction 2 phosphoglycerate and
regenerate the phospho enzyme note that
the phosphate group is in fact not
transferred this phosphate group here is
not the same that ends up on the 2
position but rather this phosphate group
gets transferred to the enzyme and the
phosphate group from the enzyme ends up
on the second position of glycerine
as we just mentioned the active form of
the enzyme has already the phosphate
bound to histidine now the question is
how did this phosphate get there in the
first place
presumably the enzyme is first
synthesized in a form that we call a po
form which does not have the phosphate
and the phosphate it's then added as a
post translational modification now our
problem suggests that one source for
this phosphate is phosphoenolpyruvate
and there's some experimental evidence
that phospho you know pyruvate can
transfer the phosphate and phosphorylate
the histidine in this enzyme now we are
asked to comment on how reasonable this
proposal is we're going to evaluate the
proposed transformation between
phosphoenol pyruvate and
phosphoglycerate mutase from two points
of view first of all is this
transformation thermodynamically
accessible and second is the
structurally feasible we know that
phosphoenolpyruvate contains a
high-energy phosphate bond that can
release a lot of energy upon hydrolysis
now if we look in our book this is the
Voting vote third edition
if you look here first of all you know
pyruvate it says releases about
sixty-two kilojoules per mole upon
hydrolysis now this is significantly
more than what energy is released by the
hydrolysis of ATP going to adp which is
only about 31 kilojoules per mole now
this should not be surprising to you
because PEP phosphoenolpyruvate
is used in the last step of glycolysis
the pyruvate kinase to phosphorylate adp
and generate ATP so the fact that has a
higher energy of hydrolysis it just
makes that transformation
thermodynamically accessible let's now
take a look at the arrow pushing
mechanism of how phosphoenolpyruvate
can phosphorylate phosphoglycerate
mutase here is the phosphoenolpyruvate
molecule and here is the histidine in
the active site of the enzyme now as you
know histidine has a pKa of about 6 so
an important fraction of the histidine
will be protonated the physiologic
pH however for this reaction to work we
need the histidine to act as a
nucleophile to attack the phosphate
therefore we're going to consider it
deprotonated now the reaction starts by
assuming there's a base in the active
site that's going to deprotonate the
histidine and then it's gonna attack the
phosphate and finally the phosphate
group is gonna leave with the assistance
of a general acid so these are the
products that we obtain this is the
phosphor enzyme was a histidine that now
has the phosphate group attached and
this is the enol that that is released
from the phosphoenolpyruvate
which is the uniform of the pyruvate now
if we evaluate the starting material and
the product in terms of their ability to
stabilize negative charge such as the
charges on the phosphate by resonance we
notice that there's no significant
difference here we have two negative
charges and one sort of phosphorus
oxygen bond that the charge can be
localized on this oxygen we also have
this carboxylate group which we also
have here so there's not a lot of
resonance stabilization between starting
materials and products so far therefore
this reaction is thermodynamically close
to neutral however notice the enol form
of pyruvate of this is in fact a very
unstable product and it likes to
tautomerize basically I summarized in
acid-base conditions - the keto form of
the pyruvate the mechanism would be as
such a base can deprotonate the you know
and then the general acid can protonate
this ch2 group to generate the keto form
in the pyruvate it turns out the Delta G
for this transformation is very negative
Delta G here is approximately minus 40
kilojoules per mole so that means this
reaction is strongly going to the right
and strongly favors the keto form so
that means parents
the transformation going from PEP and
our histidine and active site is going
to be strongly driven to the to the
right because of this keto-enol
equilibrium therefore the entire process
shown here is expected to be
thermodynamically very favorable now
let's take a look at some structural
considerations in order for PEP to
phosphorylate the enzyme it has to be
able to reach the histidine that's deep
in the active site notice that
2-phosphoglycerate
is one of the products or substrates of
the enzyme and therefore it fits very
nicely in the active site now
phosphoenolpyruvate looks a lot like to
phosphoglycerate I'm gonna sketch it
here I'm gonna have the phosphate there
and then there's a double bond at this
position so because first of all you
know pyruvate looks a lot like two
phosphoglycerate if you have no problem
fitting inside the active site of the
enzyme and reaching the active site
histidine therefore the chemical
reaction proposes this problem is quite
reasonable first of all the
thermodynamics are excellent because the
hydrolysis of phospholipid gives a lot
of energy and then the sterics are also
favorable because PEP resembles
2-phosphoglycerate one of the products
of the enzyme
part two of this problem asked us to
evaluate the consequences on the major
function of glycolysis of this reaction
that we just discussed of
phosphoenolpyruvate was phosphoglycerate
mutase here is the second half of
glycolysis going from glyceraldehyde
phosphate or gap all the way to pyruvate
as you know the main function of
glycolysis is to generate ATP and for
each molecule of glucose we have a net
generation of two molecules of ATP
now ATP is produced in two places first
at the phosphoglycerate kinase when 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate can phosphorylate
adp to generate ATP and then at pyruvate
kinase where phosphoenolpyruvate
phosphorylates adp to generate ATP now
since we start glycolysis by investing
some ATP we need 2 molecules of ATP to
phosphorylate glucose we recovered those
2 molecules of ATP at the
phosphoglycerate kinase step so all the
net production of ATP that we're getting
glycolysis comes from the pyruvate
kinase reaction shown here now if you
know pyruvate is used to phosphorylate
phosphoglycerate mutase basically it's
going to react to give the phosphate
group here it's going to generate
pyruvate but without generating ATP
right so the phosphate group goes to
this phosphoglycerate mutase and it
generates pyruvate but we get no net
production of ATP
now if PEP is used to phosphorylate
phosphoglycerate mutase it's not going
to be available for the pyruvate kinase
step but we do generate pyruvate so the
whole transformation reaches pyruvate
but without producing a net amount of
ATP of course there should not be a
significant problem as in glycolysis we
only require the enzymes in catalytic
amounts so initially we're not going to
be generating net amount of ATP until we
phosphorylate the entire pool of
phosphoglycerate mutase
after that now we have phosphoglycerate
mutase PEP is once again available for
the pyruvate kinase reaction
to generate ATP I hope you noticed that
there's a more subtle question here if
we're gonna use PEP to phosphorylate
phosphoglycerate mutase how are we gonna
get to produce PEP in the first place
since we need phosphoglycerate mutase to
go from 3 phosphoglycerate to 2
phosphoglycerate which then produces PEP
again it's kind of like one of these
chicken and the egg problems as you'll
find out many pathways feed into or
intersect with glycolysis and therefore
phosphoenolpyruvate
could in principle be made in other ways
for example in gluconeogenesis you will
see that pyruvate can lead to
oxaloacetate which then can lead to
phosphoenol pyruvate using this enzyme
called PEP carboxykinase or pepsi k so
there are ways to produce
phosphoenolpyruvate which can then say
phosphorylated phosphoglycerate mutase
which then allows the glycolysis to flow
through in the normal way well that's it
for this problem I hope you found pretty
intriguing how phosphoglycerate mutase
works now remember this is one one of
the very few enzymes in biochemistry
that utilizes the phosphorylated
histidine and this is one of the few
examples of a phosphorus nitrogen bond
we have in biochemistry also remember
the phosphoenolpyruvate is the highest
high-energy phosphate compound we have
in the body but all that hydrolysis
energy really comes from the keto enol
tautomerization equilibrium of the
pyruvate that gets released upon
hydrolysis